[Musik]
bismark erst ist brought you the munich
und sie sind auch gedacht also vielen
dank fürs kommen
heute haben wir das thema hd witsch von
irgendwo her vielleicht aus von
antwerpen und erzählt von magdeburg zwei
frauen mystikerinnen der das 13
jahrhunderts und das haben wir also die
dieses thema frauen mystic haben wir
schon bei letzte woche erlebt aber bald
von bingen natürlich aber ich wollte
trotzdem kurz was allgemeines sagen weil
jetzt werden sie den eindruck haben
im mittelalter waren all die mystiker
weiblich und deswegen gibt es so viele
weibliche philosophinnen die waren alle
aber mystikerinnen und die frage ist wie
wir diese verbindung zwischen also ist
natürlich gibt es eine größere frage die
wir irgendwie die ganze zeit schon
besprechen nämlich sind diese die
mystische texte philosophische texte
aber es gibt eine kritische frage hier
nämlich welche verbindungen wird
zwischen mystik und frauen dann
feststellen können oder sollen diese
idee dass frauen irgendwie sonderlich
anfällig sind für mystische erfahrungen
das gab es schon im mittelalter zum
beispiel wilhelm von bern sagte und
leider habe ich da nur eine englische
übersetzung dieses wissens in fantastic
operations and revelations also
offenbarungen und
wenn sie irgendwas voraussehen können
und die sind angeblich gleicher oder
leichter zu beeinflussen halt weniger
miete vorausgesagt und deswegen sind sie
buchstäblich empfänglicher man könnte
das ist natürlich mit der allgemeinen
idee das brauen passiv sind dass sie
auch in sexuelle beziehungen empfangen
dass sie geld das sie kinder empfangen
und wie gesagt ist das eigentlich ein
weil eine weit verbreitete idee im
mittelalter die man vielleicht immer
noch hat ein bisschen also wenn man an
mit löslichem mystic denkt denkt man
ziemlich schnell an frauen während wenn
man an mitleidlos wie denkt denkt man
überhaupt nicht anfahren
aber ich und es negative nicken
natürlich gibt es viele also erstens
gibt es natürlich viele männliche a
mystical im mittelalter auch
beispielsweise der inhalt von clairvaux
und meister eckhart und bonaventura und
und und es werde um das mindeste zu
sagen vorschnellen mystic als solches
mit frauen in verbindung zu setzen oder
gleichzusetzen
erstens oder mit weibliche philosophie
oder wir das beschreiben soll also
philosophie unter frauen im mittelalter
und deswegen
könnte man vielleicht vorsichtiger sein
und sagen okay es gibt natürlich nicht
in der wirklichkeit aber nach der art
nach dem mittelalterlichen verständnis
sozusagen zwei wege zu gott
ein weg der das von der besonders für
frauen geeignet ist nämlich mystik und
ein weg der besonderes für männer
geeignet ist nämlich vielleicht
philosophie oder theologie und das
könnte man dann mit diesen zwei welten
verbinden die aus universitäts das
geistige leben aus der universität und
das geistige leben innerhalb der
universität vor allem kann man das jetzt
also bei hildegard weil das
problematisch und auch einen zwölften
jahrhunderts aber jetzt sind wir ein 13
jahrhundert jetzt kann man wirklich sehr
scharf definieren es gibt scolaris muss
das passiert an der universität vor
allem in paris aber auch in oxford und
anderswo in der in italien auch wobei
weniger flüsse die in italien oder
weniger theologie also es gibt diese
zwei cern und der eine ist erde ist
wirklich nur für männer
also es gibt keine weibliches klasse
rennen an der an der universität im 13
jahrhundert wenn sie anschluss an diese
zusagen diese information oder an das
was an der universität vorgeht dann nur
indirekt die sind nie als schüler da und
natürlich nicht aus meister oder lehrer
da und deswegen könnte man vielleicht
vielleicht sagen aus dem hass mit lauter
licher sich selbst ein männlicher
mystiker benutzt irgendwie eine
weibliche methode gott zu erreichen
scola sticker einen einem ähnliche
methode
warum warum würde ein date besser zu
frauen passen als zu männer also
angeblich wegen der seele
aber das natürlich musste man das
erklären hier sind wir natürlich in
einem zeitalter wo man nicht davon
ausgeht dass die gleiche stelle in einem
mann anwesend sein kann und dann in
einer frau die wir in indien oder in der
antike gesehen haben sondern haben wir
einen kleinen körper für jede für jeden
also von daher kann man nicht unbedingt
davon ausgehen dass seelen an sich
geschlechtsneutral sind wie sie sein
müssen denn die gleiche stelle in einem
mann anwesend sein kann und dann später
in einer frau dann sogar in einem tier
also die sind so gar nicht nur
geschlechtsneutrale sondern spezies
neutral
also das ist natürlich nicht der fall
allerdings haben sie andere gründe die
sie worauf sie ist nicht rufen könnten
um zu erklären warum frauen mindestens
nichts für sozusagen der denn findungs
weg der universität geeignet sind und
das geht vor allem darum dass frauen
andere körper haben also was man sehr
oft mit in glatte literatur lesen kann
natürlich mit als die literatur die von
männern geschrieben würde ist dass
frauen besonders weiche oder feuchte
körper haben
das ist geht es zurück so antike medizin
terry es gibt diese vier eigenschaften
des körpers trocken folgt waren kaltz
und frauen sind angeblich kalt und
feucht oder nein natürlich nicht alle
frauen aber die sie neigen dazu eher
kalt und feucht zu sein
man würde dann wahrscheinlich denken
okay männer neigen dazu
beim zu sein und trocken aber nein die
neigen dazu wichtigsten seien natürlich
also wie so oft gesehen haben ist man
normativ und frau ist irgendwie defekt
oder fehler hat im vergleich zu männern
meine das ist natürlich nicht meine
technik ist die natürliche theorie ich
versuche etwas zu erklären wollten sie
auch diese diese verbindung vielleicht
kommen könnten
deswegen können wir dann denken so sind
selbst bevor wir dann tiefer in die
literatur einsteigen können wir im
voraus schon erwarten dass sie eben
diese erklärung haben könnten so sagen
männer sind gut aufgestellt körperlich
deswegen haben sie körper die ihre ihren
nationalen zellen keine probleme
vorbereiten oder weniger problematisch
sind und sie können ihre nationale
fähigkeiten einsetzen um für das visum
offizielle gießen machen bibel
auszulegen bla bla bla bla
alles was man weiß was man eines rollers
das ist was tut und dann gott erreichen
die arme frauen im gegensatz dazu haben
diese problematische körper die ihre
seelen sind davon geändert und deswegen
wenn sie an wenn sie dann gott begreifen
sollen müssen sie das anders machen wie
machen sie das ja sie warten und hoffen
dass sie glück haben und wenn sie glück
haben das ist natürlich sehr selten sind
sie sonntag hildegard von bingen
mechthild von magdeburg oder die andere
fragen die wir jetzt beschreiben in
dieser installation das heißt sie tun
nichts sie empfangen sie tun uns nichts
aktives sie empfangen einfach eine
offenbarung der seite von der seite
gottes
also das ist sozusagen eine tasche mit
deutliche theorie der frauen ist die
meiner meinung nach völlig falsch ist
ich habe hier wollt ihr das nur in vorra
schildern weil das vielleicht irgendwie
jede erwartungen entsprechen könnte
und wenn nichts denn ich glaube die
erwartungen die viele hätten ja was ich
jetzt gleich sagen leute ist das sowieso
nichts die mit der theorie ist dass mehr
unsere erwartungen von dem was die
mittels nicht die leute sagen würden
wie gesagt kann man es irgendwie da
dadurch belegen dass beim scala sticker
sagen so was wie frauen haben weiche
körper oder diese stelle die ich gerade
vorgelesen habe von wilhelm von hardware
also da sieht man definitiv dass er
mystik aus irgendwelchen gründen mit
frauen nicht gleich setzt aber er
verbindet die zwei oder sitzers frauen
wahrscheinlicher dass mystisches
einsehen dann bekommen können
und er ist natürlich ein hochklassiger
aus der universität paris also von daher
dass das beste beispiel was ich finden
konnte und das ist sehr elastisch das
wahrscheinlich viel
das sagt schon was so sieht das in
dieser mine von habe was ich dann sagen
wollte ist dass mindestens in der
mystischen literatur an sich diese
leichte verbindung zwischen mystik und
frau nichts existiert
erstens wie schon erwähnt habe gab es
ähnliche autoren und wenn wir ehrlich
sind die die berühmteste männlicher
männliche mystiker schuldigern die die
produkte mit derartigem mystiker sind
männer nicht frauen eine art von
clairvaux ist berühmt
märkte von magdeburg meister hält ist
berühmter als julian von deutsch sagt
sagt moritz oder norwich oder so was auf
deutsch 09 vi dass das in skandinavien
ist ich glaube ich werde einfach nur
absagen
auf jeden fall so also erstens dass das
ist natürlich nur ein 1 1 seiten oder
ein symptom davon dass nämlich autoren
im allgemeinen wird unter sind als bei
richard horn
also erstens dass es gibt männliche
mystiker zweitens in den mystischen
texten selbst sehen wir das geschlecht
oft als saison relativ flüssig gesehen
wird zum beispiel wir haben männliche
autoren die metaphern hernehmen wo sie
sich mit frauen vergleichen zum beispiel
dass jemand wie bernhard von clairvaux
stellt sich vor als braut des gottes
oder sowas und noch mehr sehen wir das
umgekehrt in den weiblichen autoren
sehen wir oft dass sie sich als entweder
als geschlechtslos also als and
geschlecht dass mit diesem wort
existiert also entweder das oder sogar
als männer
also wir können in den mystischen texten
beide sehen dass sie dass sie damit
herumspielen dass die männer sich als
frauen vorstellen und umgekehrt genau
weil sie diese beziehung zwischen
mystikern gott irgendwie darstellen und
wie wir oft erfahren werden wollen sie
ist ja oft diese beziehung paradox dann
vorstellen
immerhin aber was meiner meinung nach
dass das man jetzt schon sagen kann ist
dass obwohl mystik mittelalter nicht
unbedingt als weiblich gesehen würde das
würde ich nicht behaupten oder
akzeptieren
auf keinen fall was sich schon behaupten
und akzeptieren würde ist dass frauen
mit körper assoziiert sind wenn frauen
in nichts mystischen texten auftauchen
zum beispiel wenn es klassiker über
frauen das sagen dann interessieren sich
sich fast immer für irgendwas
körperliches entweder dann sprechen sie
über die körper der frauen oder die
sprechen von körperliche handlungen vor
allem natürlich sexuelle handlungen
sexuelle ethik usw
da kann oder familie da kommen immer
frauen ins spiel wenn sie auf diese
themen kommen und das heißt das dass sie
oft dass sie sehr schnell von der idee
frau zu der idee körper übergehen und es
gibt eine verbindung zwischen frauen
mystik und körper das heißt körperliche
metaphern themen sexuelle themen und
metaphern kommen sehr oft im mittelalter
ist sowieso vor und vor allem in frauen
mystik vor und an dass das hat auch die
deshalb auch viele feministinnen
ausleger der frauen mystik dann dazu
ermuntert sie sagen dass frauen
mystikerinnen oft so sagen dass das
übernommen haben also die als das
allgemeine kulturelle verständnis der
zeit wo frauen als körperlich verstanden
würden oder sozusagen durch
körperlichkeit gesehen würden und sie
dann das auf den kopf gestellt und das
um werte
das heißt sie haben gesagt ihr also all
ihr männer mit leute sagt wir sind nur
körperlich wird zeigen euch dass man
gott doch den körper erreichen kann noch
mal müssen wir vorsichtig sein diese
verbindungen zwischen körperlichkeit und
mystik kann man auch bei männlichen
autoren finden also der ihn noch mal
übertrieben zu sagen okay das ist ein
thema was wirklich für frauen ist die
charakteristisch ist aber natürlich
könnte man sagen es macht einen
unterschied ob ein wenn ein autor sagt
ich erreiche gott durch meinen körper
oder durch mindestens metaphorisch
gesehen
ich erreiche gott durch körperliche
erlebnisse natürlich macht es einen
unterschied ob eine frau das sagt oder
einmal das sagt einfach liegen dem
historischen kontext
vielleicht könnte man meinen dass wir
irgendwie als gefährlich gesehen zum
beispiel von der kirche also die kirche
sagt weg von dem körper nur an gott
denken dann kommen die mistel können
daher sagen nein nein gott durch den
körper das ist unsere strategie also man
könnte das vielleicht man kennt ihr
vielleicht erwarten dass das alles
gefährlich gesehen werden könnte
aber eigentlich im gegenteil also
natürlich gibt es gibt es schon
gegenbeispiel aber eigentlich können wir
im gegenteil sagen dass eine gewisse
formen körperlichkeit wie das hier auf
dem handy geschrieben habe als sehr
passend gesehen würde für die zwecke der
kirche in dieser zeit und das nicht ohne
grund
wie sie vielleicht verständlich alle
wissen im späten 12 und 13 jahrhundert
gab es nicht nur irgendwo sondern in
frankreich ein sehr wichtiges ereignis
was sehr viele politische und religiöse
debatten beeinflusst hat
und das war die der kreuzfahrt gegen die
katarer in südfrankreich und die charta
war ein häretiker von der sich der
kirche
natürlich war ein häretiker die man oft
mit meiner kers muss verglichen hat oder
in verbindung gebracht hat die man ich
hier vor allem wie sie hoffentlich noch
mal mit herrn wissen war das ist 16 der
vielleicht christen oder pseudo christen
die behauptet haben dass gott nur ein
prinzip der welt sei es gibt an einen
gegen prinzip ein böses prinzip und in
der house in der man action welt können
wir sagen dass das ganze universum ist
eigentlich ein raum oder ein gebiet wo
gut gegen schlechte scans und wir sind
natürlich genau in der mitte dieses
kampfes
die katarer gehen auch in diese richtung
und was sehr wichtig ist ist dass man es
muss und kann die karte haben körper oft
mit der schlechten seite das klingt wie
krieg der sterne
es gibt nicht die bösen die dunkle seite
der macht und die gute seite seite und
die dunkle seite wird sehr oft mit dem
fall in verbindung gebracht ist also zum
beispiel würden sie sagen dass sie die
die die führende kader haben sie sich
immer als rein geschrieben und wenn man
sich fragt wovon sie gereinigt würden
eine mögliche antwort ist von
körperlichkeit oder von körperliche lust
oder sowas ist praktisch
fast könnte man fast sagen das ist eine
wie eine tourismus was in diese
herrische art christentums
eingeschlichen ist interessant übrigens
zu beobachten dass sogar in der
spätantike lernen bevor die charta
gekommen sind war der als begründer des
neuen atheismus genannt wird platt putin
im dritten jahrhundert war sehr gegen
diese er hat gegen die nos ticker dann
argumentiert und gegen diese tourismus
wo man gut und schlecht hat materie und
seele materie und gott diese duale welt
so sagen können er wollte wirklich
betonen dass alles aus dem guten kommt
und damit wollte er dann auch behaupten
dass selbst der körper selbst er ist
platin ist wollte wegen seiner stadt mit
den musikern selbst er wollte behaupten
der körper ist auch gut der die nicht
geistliche sondern sinnliche welt ist
gut ist schön würde von göttlichen
prinzipien produziert in anderen
passagen spricht der andere das klingt
mehrmalig herrscht könnte man sagen
und es gibt immer dieser zug in der
platonischen tradition materie heißt das
böse zu beschreiben das tut auch dorthin
aber trotzdem offiziell ist ist an
seinen esprit teams lehre dass körper
gut sind und dass die körperliche welt
gut ist wenn wir dann wieder zum 13
jahrhundert zu bekommen können wir
deswegen sagen wenn musiker
die musikerinnen kommen uns sagen der
körper ist mein weg zu gott
also ich empfange sein einfluss durch
meinen körper und natürlich
also das kann in den texten die wir
jetzt besprechen werden ist das
eigentlich ganz abstrakt internet
metapher normalerweise aber natürlich
wissen sie es gibt immer diese fälle wo
zum beispiel franz von assisi hat diese
städte bekommen also die diese
körperliche zeichen der das muss oder
dieser besonderen beziehung zu gott
waren natürlich sehr weit verbreitet
mittelalter nun das war gut
aus sicht der kirche man könnte wie
gesagt man könnte meinen es gleich
schlecht aus sicht der kirche war das zu
sagen wie ein anderer weg zu gott dich
herum aber viel mehr haben würde das
eigentlich als eine art manierismus
gesehen und da die charta sich das
bereit waren für jede klasse zu sterben
und als märtyrer zu sterben war es auch
nicht schlecht wenn mystic bereit waren
zu sterben für das was sie glaubten oder
metaphorisch sterben und wir werden
sehen dass diese musikerinnen oft sagen
ich sterbe vorliebe für gott wenn solche
sachen
was man auch nicht vergessen soll ist
das christentum an sich das könnte man
mit aller vorsicht als eine körperliche
religion beschreiben ist so fern dass
die eine zentrale lehre des christentums
ist natürlich die inkarnation was ist
das eigentlich was christentum
auszeichnet und den abrahamitischen
religionen judentum islam christentum
aus sicht der muslime und juden das was
die christen wirklich gekennzeichnet hat
war jede
schwerst schwer verständlichen glaube
dass gott drei und eins ist und das ist
natürlich wichtig aber was auch sehr
wichtig ist ist dass der die zweite
person gottes ist mensch geworden und
war von daher war christentum immer
eigentlich zugeneigt den körper nichts
zu entwerten oder oder nicht zu
akzeptieren dass körperlich sein ist
unbedingt schlecht weil christus war
körperlich und auch gott gleichzeitig
und deswegen kann man auch behaupten
dass diese diese körperliche themen die
wir in frauen mystik finden sind
sozusagen echt christlich und würde
eigentlich gerne übernommen auch in der
also oder mindestens an haben gute
empfang selbst bei zb scola sticker
gefunden
denken wir noch mal ein handy hat von
denen sie hat dann wirklich viel respekt
von männlichen autoren derzeit zum
beispiel trainer von bravo gewonnen
obwohl sie frau war dort die mystikerin
war also die zwar irgendwie sehr
willkommen im allgemeinen für das
publikum dieser zeit und eigentlich kann
man das gleiche über frauen wichtig im
allgemein sagen
mit der kleinen ausnahme von keyboards
die wir nächste woche kennenlernen
werden und wir werden sehen was passiert
wenn eine frau die mystikerin ein
bisschen zu weit geht
oder vielleicht sogar viel zu weit okay
hat jemand fragen oder darstellungen zu
diesem thema bevor ich dann zu die zwei
hauptpersonen komme weil heute die zwei
hauptdarsteller der heutigen geschichte
sind handewitt und mechthild von
magdeburg
wir sind ein bisschen besser über merkel
informiert ein beispiel wir wissen
ungefähr wann sie gestorben ist nämlich
1282 hd witsch ist dürfte etwas früher
sein und um beide zu verstellen müssen
wir ein bisschen unser wissen mit dem
thema beginnen beschäftigen beginnen war
das war eine eine große bewegung im 13
jahrhundert das dauerte bis ins 14
jahrhundert wo das dann endlich von dem
papst gestoppt würde die wir nächste
woche sehen wenn aber im dritten
jahrhundert würde das sogar durch den
papst offiziell erlaubt es gab auch
übrigens männlich sozusagen männliche
beginnen diesen beiden nicht beginnen
also beginne heißt muss weiblich sein
tipp das war heiss weibliche weibliche
religiöse personen die allerdings keine
nonne geworden ist also die haben dass
das musste ich nachschauen nachschlagen
und die hat entdeckt es gibt ein
deutsches wort dafür ordnance geliebte
also dh sie haben keine ort kennen sie
alle dieses wortes ordnungs
ordensgelübde haben weil das haben sie
nicht gemacht
im gegensatz zu nennen also die sie
sie haben dann ist es was als ob sie
genau wie nonnen leben in einer gemeinde
mit anderen frauen zusammen
nichts in einer familie aber ohne zu
versprechen dass sie das selber machen
genügt aber doch gesagt und an und hier
gesagt habe ich glaube nicht dass mystik
im allgemeinen als die regios empfunden
würde von seiten der kirche waren die
beginn also die die waren schon nervös
wegen den beginnen weil sie das leben
als ob sie dann sozusagen mit christus
verheiratet sind aber sie dürfen immer
noch immer wieder aussteigen
und das heißt dass man sozusagen nie im
voraus wissen kann ob eine beginne doch
einmal heiratet oder verkürzt oder was
auch immer
und was wirklich schlimm war oder
möglich möglicherweise schlimmer als
seite der kirche ist dass sie immer noch
sozial engagiert waren aber im kloster
zum beispiel hildegard oder jemand wie
handy gehört sie ist nicht umsonst dass
das wort kloster für uns heißt so was
wie abgeschlossen von der welt die waren
abgeschlossen von der welt sie leben im
kloster auf englisch mindestens kann man
sogar sagen hat mit peter tosh und das
heißt abgeschlossen hast du kannst von
irgendwas kreis tödlich sein
das heißt du kommst nicht dran
die beginn war nicht so die müssten geld
verdienen und das haben sie vor allem
nähen und sollten und textil arbeit
gemacht und es das hieß dass sie in
kontakt mit geschäftsmännern gekommen
sind und im allgemeinen mit der ganzen
bevölkerung der stadt wo sie gelebt
haben
sie lebten übrigens vor allem in
nordeuropa damaligen also im jahr 2010
in deutschland auch frankreich und das
hieß dass sie in einer so genannten
grauzone gelebt haben
zwischen dem gepflasterten leben und dem
normalen leben und sie waren deswegen
etwas seltsam und unheimlich für die
cavs autoritäten und wie gesagt zuerst
würden sie erlaubt das zu tun und dann
nach einer weile würde das dann gestoppt
ist da übrigens nicht nur die
möglichkeit für diese frauen netz
anderen nichts beginnen in kontakt zu
kommen sondern kann das wirklich vor und
zwar sie wollten sie wollten eigentlich
das wort gottes verbreiten in einer
ähnlichen worten weise art und weise wie
die bettler ordnung wie zum beispiel die
dominikaner umfasst franziskaner
natürlich waren was alle die wird es für
das öffnen des 19 jahrhunderts entweder
dominikaner oder franziskaner thomas von
aquin des coaches
albertus magnus und die diese battle
ordnungen waren für frauen nicht offen
und was sie von normalen menschen
unterschieden hat es jetzt heißt die die
battle butler die dort amerika zum
beispiel jetzt dass sie positioniert
haben also die sind rausgegangen und
haben versucht alle zusagen zu gott zu
rufen fragen konnten das nicht machen
die dürften diese diesen ordnung nicht
rein und und vielleicht deswegen kam die
beginn die beginnen bewegungen
das ist praktisch eine was wie ein
ersatz kommt auch fast genau
gleichzeitig mit den bettlern
also von daher könnten wir vielleicht
sogar sagen dass hd witsch und märkte
sind fast die die weibliche fassungen
von thomas fleck weg von akin hans
gottes alleine gesellschaftlich gesehen
nicht von dem inhalt her
und bedenkt an manche leute würden sogar
sagen dass mit dieser mit dieser und
ähnlichen bewegungen dass wir eine art
demokratisierung in der religion haben
wo wir zuvor also im elften jahrhundert
zum beispiel oder selbst einen solchen
jahrhundert noch haben wir eine
situation wo religiöse glaube immer
durch priester verbreitet würde also das
wort gottes kam von der kirche und die
ich glaube ich habe das schon wo er
irgendwann gesagt die kirche war oder
vielleicht habe ich das in dem podcast
gesagt aber ich habe gesagt die die
kirche war wie eine eine
parallelregierung in mittelalter es gab
22 sehr hierarchisch organisationen die
die gesellschaft kontrolliert haben im
mittelalter nämlich die säkulare
regierung und die kirche und die kirche
war wirklich wie eine zweite regierung
die hatten einen könig der papst der hat
sich wie er hat sich wie ein könig
benommen hatte sogar erwähnt so weiter
und dann kommen diese bewegung sozusagen
von unten und sagen nein wirken auch das
wort gottes erklären verbreiten wir
können auch leute ermuntern mit sünden
aufzuhören und so weiter also praktisch
alles was die priester machen und wir
können auch tiefer nachdenken was die
prinzipien dieser aufgabe sein könnten
und das ist genau was diese zwei
autorinnen machen und dass das könnte
man mit vorsicht vielleicht sogar als
eine vorahnung des protestantismus
einschätzen weil es ist wirklich wie
eine art religiös zu sein nichts
natürlich völlig außerhalb der kirche
war protestantisch ist das nicht aber
irgendwie mit anderen mitteln und vor
allem mit einer anderen hat autorität
als die die der kirche immer zugeordnet
würde
okay so natürlich sollen sie nicht den
eindruck haben dass alle beginn
philosophen waren das bei weitem nicht
der fall die meisten wollen einfach froh
mehr frauen die tests innerhalb breit
gemacht haben und das gemacht haben was
ich gerade beschrieben haben
aber es ist sehr auffällig dass die
haupt philosophinnen der zeit zwischen
anfang des zweiten jahrhunderts und
platz 13 115 oder so ich glaube die
beginnt in bewegung ist ungefähr damals
gescheitert dann die drei hauptfiguren
sind handewitt wechselt und margarete
die vielleicht eine beginne war also
diese bewegung war es so sagen dass
zusammenhang für frauen klose wie im 13
jahrhundert kann man sagen
oder vielleicht nicht vorschnell
verlosen wir sagen frauen müssten es
gibt auch zum beispiel bezirks von
nazareth die eine ähnliche autoren ist
und es gibt andere und es symbolisiert
fast das was ich gerade gesagt habe über
die demokratisierung der region und
religiösen lehre
das natel hdw und margaret alle auf alle
volks sprachige texte geschrieben haben
trat sogar drei verschiedene sprachen
hdj hat aus mitleid hatten mit laki
holländisch geschrieben vielleicht hieß
es damals deutsch nicht hält hat
mittelniederdeutsch geschrieben und
natürlich schreibt margrit derartige
französisch das heißt nicht unbedingt
dass das heißt gar nichts sogar dass die
mittel mittelniederdeutsch lesen müssen
um märkte zu lesen denn die
ursprüngliche fassung ihres werkes ist
nicht erhalten leider sie würde aber in
mittelhochdeutsch übersetzt und sogar
ich kann das fast lesen wie habe texte
auf meiner website hochgeladen die sie
lesen können übrigens apropos putin
begründet dass in schuss hält
das ist das kennwort für die texte also
platin alles klein geschrieben wenn es
sie dann in die website gehen sie werden
sehen ich habe die für jede woche habe
ich texte verfügbar gemacht und ihr habt
die irgendwie hab nebeneinander
mittelhochdeutscher text und deutsche
also moderne deutsche übersetzung und
vor allem wenn man zuerst die
übersetzung liest und das tun die alte
fassung zu lesen das ist wirklich
verständlich und man sieht was die man
sieht sofort welche deutsche wörthersee
hat es ist ganz interessant also war für
mich interessant vielleicht haben sie
alle mit überhaupt deutsch gelernt
ein an der schule das macht man doch
oder
nein nicht das ist für mich ein bisschen
wie charles fränkl und ungefähr aus der
gleichen zeit ich glaube diese
übersetzung ist es sogar aus dem 14
jahrhundert features bei heike witsch
haben wir sogar die originalfassung
also wir haben die holländische texte
die sie geschrieben hat ist nicht ganz
klar wo hd wird gelebt hat diese idee
dass sie von antwerpen kommt das
passiert sich auf eine ein sehr später
text von ihr die der mit also eine späte
kopie eines textes von ihr und das würde
mit dem überschrift mit der wirtschaft
gezeichnet von hd wird von antwerpen
nicht sehr zahlungs wert man sonst
können wir nur sagen dass die
handschriften aus dieser gegend kommen
aber sie will wissen hausinternen
belegen dass sie beginn ihrer und dass
sie anscheinend streits mit ihren
kommilitonen hatte und dann würde sie
vielleicht sogar rausgeschmissen oder
weggeschickt weil sie schreibt in einem
brief die traurig sie ist dass sie
nichts bei der früheren gemeinde ist man
hat den eindruck dass irgendwas schief
gegangen ist und dass sie da raus
geschmissen weil es nicht ganz klar
mechthild kennen wir eigentlich nur
durch diesen berg aber es sie sagt die
relativ viel über sich selbst
in diesem werk beide beschreiben sie wie
wie es gekommen ist dass sie in der lage
waren diese taktisch zu schreiben und
merkel sagt sogar dass das buch was sie
geschrieben hat das buch heißt das
fließende nicht der gottheit sie sagt
sogar dass das buch eigentlich von gott
geschrieben würde und ihr mehr oder
weniger diktiert sie sagt auf sachen wie
gott sagte zu mir
text oder man steigt einfach rein und
man würde denken dann ganz normal text
aber es gibt eine passage wo sie
wirklich sagt dieses buch sei von gott
und noch mehr sogar der titel ist von
gott dass gott gefragt wie das buch
heißen sollte oder bleibt leider einfach
gesagt das buch heißt das wesen der
liegt der gottheit und nochmal deswegen
können wir sagen da ist wie hildegard
sie ein gewisses erlaubnis haben alles
ist alles zu sagen was sie wollen oder
vielleicht angesichts margherita nichts
alles zu sagen was sie wollen aber
einiges zu sagen weil sie eben da also
aus unserer sicht würden wahrscheinlich
sagen sie stecken sich hinter gott sagen
ja das sagt er nicht ich also ihr hört
ihn an hört mich nicht an
aber meine mutter ist in seine wörter
also hört mich an
[Musik]
ja die ist wie gesagt also das hauptwerk
von mertens das ist das einzige werk von
hier dass das wesen der gottheit wir
haben dann von hd witsch mehrere werke
die zusammen in handschriften gefunden
werden nämlich mehrere briefe wie den
der brief den ich gerade erwähnt habe
viele gedichte und manchmal mit prosa
oder mit 1 in verschiedenen rhythmen
kombiniert dass man beim gemischt und
die hauptwerke 14 visionen das ist
natürlich mit hildegard zu vergleichen
also haben genau wie helga da haben wir
diese idee
sie beschreibt sehr beeindruckende
visionen und erklärt dann was das heißen
könnte wie bitte
also allein an der tatsache dass sie
beginnen wollen volkssprache die werke
verfasst haben können wir sofort sagen
okay das sind wird das sind autorinnen
die außerhalb der klassischen welt
stehen
das sind keine repräsentanten des
rassismus und sie setzen sich nichts mit
klassischen themen auseinander
übrigens nichts zu vergessen ist dass
wir haben gesehen dass hildegard das
doch gemacht hatte also sie hat diesen
brief bekommen wo sie sich zu einer
lehre von david vom portier äußern
sollte er gesagt nein das ist falsch
blablabla das kommt bei denen mit vor
und wenn sie die schola sticker benennen
oder besprechen
das ist immer entweder einfach zu sagen
das bin nicht ich
also ich bin nicht geleert zum beispiel
im märz sagt dass sie kein gelernt
geistliche man sein dass das ist
übrigens orient die originale deutsche
farce mittelhochdeutsche also nicht die
originale aber die die mittel deutsche
übersetzung die keines einzigen
mindestens diese drei wörter sofort
verstehen und sie sagt ich würde nichts
zu sein in der in der schule also ist
klassisch ausgebildet mein meister dass
gott also mein mann war gestern
würde man auf lateinisch sein also das
ist sozusagen gleich seite irgendwie sie
will zugeben dass sie nicht gebildet ist
aber dann gleichzeitig will sie sagen
aber ich muss nicht gebildet sein mein
meister ist gott
die ab was besseres sozusagen
und die wenn es nicht so stark die
margaret macht wie wir letzte nächste
woche sehen werden aber trotzdem ab und
zu äußern sie sich kritisch den
klassikern gegenüber als nicht nur dass
sie keines klassiker sind sie sagen auch
dass an so soll ich sagen wir ja die
sind so gut gebildet diese diese männer
aber trotzdem verstehen sie nichts oder
trotzdem kommen sie in ketzerei die
hildegard gesagt hat oder was nicht sagt
ist dass sie für die liebe gott nicht
offen sind und als sie beschreibt sie
als die wiese von lehre also die weise
von herrn von lehrer haben die die
ausgebildet sind
die haben vielleicht viel wissen habe
keine liebe und das bringt mich an
[Musik]
nein noch nichts sagen das bringt mich
zum hauptthema was liebe ist aber ich
wollte zuerst etwas vorlesen dass das
kommt aus einer beschreibung von merck
hält wie es gekommen ist dass sie ihr
buch geschrieben hat
ok also sie sagt dass sie sagt es
anziehst das noch dass er nochmal
einhelliger dass sie das ist schon als
kennt diese momente hatte wo sie
einfluss von gott bekommen hat
[Musik]
nun scheint wie viele lesen wollte so
fertig dass die wirte wechsels von
magdeburg
während der ganzen zeit bevor ich dieses
buch begann und bevor ein einziges
seiner worte von gott meine seele kam
hatte ich als einer der anfälligsten
menschen geht die man jemals ein
geistliches leben für und sah von des
teufels bosheit wusste ich nichts die
schwäche der welt kannte ich nichts die
falschheit der menschen im geistlichen
stand war mir auch unbekannt ich muss
reden um der erde gottes willen und auch
in der lehre die dieses buch enthält
ich bin würde gesünder denn würde in
meinem zwölften lebensjahr als ich
allein war von brust des heiligen
geistes mit so über strömender macht's
getroffen dass ich mich zu kleiner
lässliche sünde schwerer harz mehr
bereit finden konnte
der überaus liebe gruß würde mir täglich
zuteil und verleitete mir mit seiner
liebe die süßigkeit der ganzen welt und
er wird noch stärker von tag zu tag
so geschah es während mehr als 31 jahren
ich wusste von passiert das heißt wir
können jetzt mehr oder weniger eröffnen
sie es jetzt zwölf plus 31 also denke
dass es 43 also sie hat das buch mit 43
verfasst
ich wusste von gott nichts mehr als die
christlichen glaubens wahrheiten aber
ich bemühte mich stets mein herz rein zu
halten
gott selbst ist mein zeuge dafür dass
ich ihn nie weder wirklich noch mit
heimlichen verlangen darum bat er möge
mir die dinge offenbaren die in diesem
buch ausgezeichnet sind
ich hätte auch nie gedacht dass menschen
so etwas geschehen konnte
solange ich bei meinen verwandten und
bei meinen bekannten lebte denen ich
immer ganz besonders lieb war
was die ich von diesen dingen nichts nun
war es schon länger zeit mein wunsch
gewesen ohne eigene schuld erniedrigt zu
werden
da begab ich mich als liebe zu gott an
einen ort wo ich keinen freund hatte aus
einem einzigen menschen wegen dieses
einen hatte ich angst dass mir die firma
erniedrigung und damit die leute
leider gottes liebe nicht zugestanden
würden aber gott ließ mich nirgends
allein und für ziemlich in solingen de
süßigkeiten so hellige heilige
erkenntnis und in so unfassbar der
wunder dass mir die irdischen dinge
völlig fremd wurden und dann geht es
weiter
aber sie sie haben schon einen eindruck
wie das funktioniert als sie sieht sich
zurück von der welt wird beginne und
empfängt dieses licht von gott wollte
noch mal darauf aufmerksam machen was
sie hier sagt gibt sie sagt ich habe
gott nie darum bat vermöge mir die dinge
offenbar die in diesem buch
ausgezeichnet sind
ich persönlich würde gerne die die alte
deutsche fassung verlesen aber das
bringt nicht zusammen nein aber das
können sie im internet sehen
auf jeden fall die das unterstützt das
was sie vorher gesagt habe
das müsst ihr für deinen sieht oft als
passiv darstellen
also ist denn nur empfänger die sind wie
radio empfänger und gotthard ist ein
funk aus und die zigarette empfangen
vielleicht könnte man sogar sagen dass
ein punkt wäre vielleicht das kann jedem
passieren so nochmal diese
demokratisierung also man muss nichts
durch man muss nicht theologie an der
universität studieren man muss nur aus
gewährt werden
also man könnte das mit dieser mit
diesem prozess verbinden
auch könnte man sagen sie es ein
bisschen wie ein prophet in der bibel
wie wir auch bei hildegard festgestellt
haben
aber mein punkt ist dass das ist
wirklich kein angeblich natürlich ist
das kein aktives verfahren
sie ist nur
ein rohr durch den wir gott hören können
sprachrohr für gott und vielleicht
könnte man auch deswegen denken dass sie
dass sie selbst überhaupt nichts über
ihre intellektuelle fähigkeiten dann
behaupten will
aber das wäre falsch ich lese noch mal
den letzten satz gott ließ mich nirgends
allein und führte mich ein service der
selling der süßigkeit in so heilige
erkenntnis und in so unfassbare wunder
dass wir die jährigen dinge völlig fremd
würden das als deutsches wort für
erkenntnis ist bekanntheit
sie versteht irgendwas was sie vorher
nicht verstand und was sie hier
schildern will ist nicht das an dass sie
sozusagen ohne verständnis einfach vor
sich hin spricht als ob sie manchmal
stellt man sich vor dass mystiker
vielleicht war diese ekstatische
zustände manchmal haben wo sie plötzlich
reden können und das wort gottes sich
äußern können dann fallen sie wieder hin
und haben nichts mehr zu sagen das ist
nichts das was sie behaupten das kommt
so im allgemeinen bei diesen fragen ist
herr innen nie vor
dann sehen sie haben schon die idee ich
kann manchmal gott begreifen man nichts
aber sprechen können sie aber also sie
die haben eine eigene stimme so sagen
und wann haben sie 1 1 einige einziges
verständnis denn es die geht dann weiter
und sagt sie nachdem sie diese
erlebnisse hatte konnte sie sagt das
sage ich mit den augen meiner seele in
himmlische herrlichkeit die
menschennatur unseren herrn jesus
christus
ich erkannte in seiner mehr haben als
die heilige dreifaltigkeit die
häufigkeit des vaters blablabla das
heißt die engel
also kurzum versteht es die ganzen
inhalt der christlichen lehre und das
ist wirklich verständnis dass sie
bekommt sie sind nicht nur so sagen ein
text den sie nicht verstehen kann
arm ist viel das ist nicht unbedingt so
sein national als auch nicht anti
nationales hat irgendwas mit ihrem
intellekt zu tun was hier vorgeht
die frage war dann für sie wie sie
vorgehen sollte also wie sie merkt
vorgehen sollte ein bisschen wie
hildegard die bernhard von clairvaux
fragen wollte was sie mit ihren
mystischen hervor wie ab sie hat ihre
mystische erfahrungen reagieren sollte
und das ist sehr ähnlich was geschehen
ist sie hat dann einen bekannten gehabt
da hieß heinrich von halle und da ist
sie dass er erzählte was ihr geschehen
ist hat er praktisch gesagt ja also wenn
du ein buch von gott bekommen hast musst
du das müsste das unterschreiben und das
hat sie dann gemacht und dann hat hat
sie ihn das gezeigt und er war
schockiert von dem inhalt inhalt werde
ich natürlich gleich beschreiben und hat
das wissen wir noch mal nur wegen hier
des texters sie sagt sie sagt dass sie
das ihm gezeigt hat und dass er
überrascht war und dann sagte sie so hin
ich bin überrascht dass du überrascht
wirst es sehr schön und anscheinend man
hat den eindruck wenn man ein bisschen
hinter nachdenkt was da geschehen ist
man hat den eindruck dass sie ein
briefwechsel oder vielleicht waren sie
zusammen also eine sie haben darüber
gesprochen was in dem buch war und er
war am ende zufrieden damit vielleicht
und er hat ihr geholfen das buch zu
veröffentlichen
sozusagen
die sie
sie hat dann auch andere kritiker die
auf das buch reagiert haben weil sie
weil sie psychologische ansätze in dem
buch nicht gut gefunden haben und dass
wir ziemlich detailliert aber werden nur
zwei lieblingsstellen von mir zitieren
jemand hat mir gesagt wenn wenn du
solche sachen schreibst musst du davon
ausgehen oder dass sie dich dafür
vorbereiten dass das buch verbrannt
werden könnte
und sie sagt dass gott ihr dann danach
bekannt gemacht hat dass man die
wahrheit nicht verbrennen kann hektar
also erstens dass und zweitens gibt es
eine stelle wo sie berichtet dass an
eine theologische behauptung die sie
machte auf kritik gestoßen ist
den könnt ihr gesagt du hast recht ich
aber auch sie war ziemlich selbstbewusst
kann man sagen okay jetzt an zum
hauptthema dieser zwei werken und das
ist eigentlich das thema was alle
netzwerk verbinden wenn sie überhaupt
was mit den verbänden und das ist das
thema der liebe liebe heißt in beiden
sprachen damals mit
mini ist weiblich das nicht und wissen
und wichtig und die also die
grundlegende idee ist natürlich sie
schreiben über ihre liebe für gott und
nicht eigentlich nichts was wir
vielleicht erwarten könnten nämlich über
die liebe gottes für sie dass es nicht
das thema das thema in der sie sind der
liebhaber sie sind die liebhaberinnen
gott ist das geliebte aber was wirklich
was wirklich spannend ist ist das das
hab ich was jetzt gerade fast gesagt
hatte wird und dann haben möchte
die sind sich vor ort nicht als
liebhaberinnen sondern als liebhaber
also männlich das ist ein beispiel von
dem was sie vorher gesagt habe dass in
diesen texten oft geschlechts die
spielen mit geschlechts ein bisschen
oder sogar sehr viel
das heißt auf englisch manchmal channel
branding und die machen das deswegen
weil sie eine art literatur zugang
hatten die sie sehr beeinflusst hat und
dass das heißt auf englisch
courtney love wie man heißt auf deutsch
und mini gesagt habe ich herausgefunden
ich weiß nicht ob sie mit dieser
literatur verteilt sind es gibt zum
beispiel mit johannes kapelle es gibt
vieles was ich schon letzte woche
erwähnt habe und ähnliche sachen und das
thema ist oder die die geschichte in
seinem werk ist eigentlich immer
derselbe wir haben einen liebhaber nun
erstens nach seine geliebte
das ist eine schöne frau oder eine rose
in romantisches und die jungs
symbolisiert die frau oder vielleicht
ein aspekt oder sogar tv
und in wenigen ministern
was dann passiert ist dass der liebhaber
leidet ganz ganz fürchterlich weil die
geliebte nichts da ist und sie weiß
wahrscheinlich nicht einmal dass er
existiert und er weiß wenn er schreibt
gedichte und und und und natürlich sehen
wir dass wir sehen auch daran sogar bei
dante wir haben die geschichte über
praktische und wie er sie gesehen hat
und weil natürlich ist immer also beim
gleich gleich bei mannschaft ist beim
ersten klick blitz liebe ja und dann
geht es weiter und manchmal wenn es gut
ausgeht kann der liebhaber endlich die
geliebte dann irgendwie gewinnen
er muss oft wie gesagt nicht nur leiden
sondern verschiedene sachen dann
unternehmen um die geliebte zu gewinnen
und so weiter und so fort
ok und das war das war natürlich eine
sehr weit verbreitete art literatur
ich würde fast sagen dass zu übernehmen
vermittelt und harwich werde fast als ob
ein religiöser autor jetzt actionfilme
oder star trek oder was übernehmen würde
um ihre liebe für gott zu erklären das
ist praktisch nur populäre literatur
derzeit also was sie damit aber machen
ist wirklich sehr interessant wie gesagt
sie stellen sich als der liebhaber da
und gott ist die geliebte und es wird
wirklich sehr detailliert beschrieben
und ist es wirklich sehr ausdrücklich
dass das eine sexuelle beziehung
vergleicht und ich wollte eine gute
stelle als hd witsch vorlesen leider ist
das nur habe ich das nur
auf englisch zur verfügung also das
werde ich auf englisch vorlesen passiert
ist kommt aus dem siebten vision von hd
fitch sieht also der zusammenhang ist
sie beschreibt ihre liebe für diesen
mann und der mannes jesus christus
[Musik]
danny games oft wie in der shape auf das
am 1 in dieser wurden als der castor
sein engagement von thatchers in formen
customs also brot und wein hat sich zu
mir als brot und wein gegeben
was passiert hier
ja die war nicht ganz
wer hd bridge oder die übersetzung das
werden wir sehen
ich beurteile nichtig erklären uhr okay
so was passiert hier also sie fängt und
das geht zurück zu was ich gesagt habe
mit christlicher lehre
sie fängt mit der inkarnation an also
gott ist zu mir gekommen als man also
sagt er er ist zu mir gekommen in
gestalt einer eines menschen und er war
sehr schön und dann kam als brot und
wein also bisher sind wir praktisch
innerhalb der normalen christlichen
lehre und dann fünf erweitert sie nur
diese dieser gedanken in diesen
gedankengang und sagt dann kam er
wirklich zu mir was was wäre das das
werde anstatt das wäre eine sexuelle
beziehung also wir und sie sagt unsere
glieder waren auch meine glieder und ich
war genügt also es war praktisch sah das
war ein und dann und dann sagt sie ich
konnte das eine zeit lang aushalten aber
dann ist er verschmolzen kritisch und es
in mir gekommen bis wir einst waren
und das ist übrigens die das moment wo
die andere mittelalterliche leser
wahrscheinlich seien würden dass sie
nicht sauber ist
es ist eine art an die eine hat
deflation
sie wird gott oder sie wird vielleicht
für nichtstun in gott aufgenommen
dieses thema ist bei hatte virgin nicht
unbedingt so stark vorhanden aber es
beiden wie wir es ändern es bei margaret
sehr stark also hier hat ihre hauptidee
ist die vernichtung
der mystikerin wo sie in gott
aufgenommen wird und verschmilzt okay
und wir finden ähnliche sachen bei
mechthild wo sie auch ihre erotische
beziehung zu gott bescheid
das lese ich auch kurz vor also ist
jetzt mit mechthild aus buch eines
kapitel 44 was der offiziellen übrigens
passiert sind dialoge zwischen der
liebhaber und die geliebte oder zwischen
braut und bräutigam und sie sagt das
sagt unser herr bleibt stehen edle seele
was gebetet du her
ihr sollt euch ausziehen herr was wir
dann mit mir geschehen isele ihr seid
meine natur so innig verbunden das gar
nichts zwischen euch und mir sein darf
niemals war ein engel so erhaben dass
ihm auch nur für einen augen einen augen
glück zuteil geworden wäre was euch auf
ewig zu aigners darum sollte ehrfurcht
und charme ablegen und jede äußere typen
vielmehr soll tier allein die tugenden
die ihr von natur aus in ihrem innern hp
gefühl das ist euer edles belangen und
heuer ähnliches begehren diese wenn ich
in ewigkeit und mit meiner unendlichen
gnade stellen herr nun bin ich eine
nackte säle und du in dir selbst ein
gott in großer helligkeit unser beider
gemeinschaft ist das ewige leben ohne
tod darauf tritt da einiges selige
stille ein wie es beide wollen
er schenkt sich ihr und sie schenkt sich
ihm was ihr jetzt geschieht das weiß sie
und dies dies ist mein trost
nun kann dies nicht lange werden wo zwei
liebende heimlich zusammen kommen müssen
sie immer wieder auseinandergehen und es
sich doch zu trennen
also ziemlich klar
okay was interessant ist ist aber und
was wirklich auffällt ist sind diese
momente der vereinigung mit gott sexuell
dargestellt oder geschildert aber das
ist das wirklich vorlesen weil es sehr
berühmt und wie gesagt sehr auffällt
aber so ein bisschen irreführend
was wirklich sehr dass diese momente in
den texten das kommerziell selten vor
diese momente wo sich wirklich die
vereinigung beschreiben was viel öfter
vorkommt ist dieses leiden und sehnen
nach gott also die die beide die die die
weinen und fühlt sich verlassen denken
dass er nie wieder kommt und uns das ist
und das ist der grund wofür man das sehr
gute netz - an vergleichen kann
was interessant ist ist dass sie dass
sie dieses leiden und die märkte auf
sagt verworfenheit sie beschreiben das
nicht mein stil ist sie sagen dass das
irgendwie die richtige beziehung ist zu
gott und wobei es sind sie ist sehr
schmerzvoll schmerzhaft und schlimm aber
das ist also sagen die richtige
einstellung gott gegenüber von einer
geschaffenen serie die nur in dessen
fall kurz ihn kontaktieren kann könnte
man sagen also die nur auf ab und zu an
gott rankommen rankommen kann und
deswegen ist es schmeckt zum beispiel hd
witsch von unglaube
das heißt die überzeugung zu haben dass
gott nie wiederkommt und das ist die die
ich glaube ich würde sagen das ist die
religiöse einstellung schlechthin ist
nicht glaube sondern unklar wird es
natürlich wieder so ein paradox wie wir
so oft bei diesen arten finden
also die idee ist jeweils verzweifelter
ich werde desto mehr entspricht meine
einstellung die große distanz zwischen
mir und gott gott ist allen märkten ist
jenseits meiner art von existenz
deswegen kann ich nur nach ihnen und
hoffen dass er zu mir kommt was auch
sehr typisch für ministern ist ist dass
sie dieses leiden irgendwie genießen
also diese idee dass dass das leiden süß
ist es gibt noch eine eine schöne stelle
aus merzenich tiefer sinkt hier ich süße
getränke also je tiefer ich denke dass
du sollst dich und die idee dass sie von
gott in fremde sind also diese diese
idee dass der liebhaber entfernt ist von
der geliebten und deswegen nur hoffen
kann dass er sie wieder erblicken kann
diese ewigen das paar die idee dass dass
man gott erblicken kann kommt auch bei
madrids vor so dass sich mit von seinem
gesicht sein scheint und die hoffnung
dass sie hat ihn wieder zu erblicken
das passt alles sehr gut in diesem
muster von ministern und ist eigentlich
eine art und weise die die entfremdung
oder die die distanz zwischen gott und
geschaffene zähle zu beschreiben ok
jetzt die frage die große frage
inwiefern ist das als philosophie
wann haben sie sich wahrscheinlich
mindestens eine halbe stunde geplagt und
ich denke erstens könnten wir haben wir
vielleicht ein vorteil was wir
beseitigen wollen bevor wir die frage
der philosophie überhaupt die frage
erspart das philosophische oder nicht
der vorteil ist natürlich ist das nichts
philosophie war das ist mystik und
mystik mystik ist nicht philosophie
müsste ich jetzt anti nationalistische
dass wir das islamistisch und deswegen
ist interessant zu sehen dass genau wie
bei hildegard weil wir haben nicht
vergessen wir haben bemerkt dass
hildegard sehr oft von vernunft spricht
man sagt das gut sein also ethisch oder
moralisch zu leben ist vernünftig zu
leben also sie setzt immer fern und über
die lust sagt verluste besiegen bla bla
bla bla dann das passiert in hd bridge
und an märkten nicht so ausdrücklich
waren nicht im zusammenhang der ethik
aber vor allem hdj erwähnt vernunft ab
und zu und bündnis ein interessantes
wort dafür nämlich reden und reden heißt
natürlich sprechen aber auch vernunft
hat anscheinend im deutsch dieser zeit
es ist zum beispiel hat sie eine lange
passage wo vernunft als ein symbolischer
allegorische figur auftaucht und von
liebe gekrönt wird also ihre idee ist
das sprechen beziehungsweise vernunft
wird es ist praktisch der weg wodurch
wir soli bekommen und liebe es dann die
vollendung dieses dieses wegs
sie sagt schon das paar am ende muss sie
mitreden aufhören es gibt sozusagen
nichts mehr zu sagen dass wir in diesem
wettbewerb ist ein vielleicht aber es
ist wichtig dass sie obwohl sie diese
momente haben die vielleicht jenseits
der sprache sind wo sie gott begreifen
können und also diese momente die
sexuell beschrieben werden
das ist vielleicht irgendwie jenseits
der sprache und jenseits der vernunft
sie kommen immer wieder runter und
setzten vermummt und sprache ein um die
das problem darzustellen und das und das
ist das bringt mich dazu zu sagen was
ich wirklich philosophisch an den texten
finde das ist eigentlich der psychologie
lassen lassen sie mich erklären das
immer geht es natürlich viel lieber
wissen ja also die die bedingungen des
westens sie gehen davon aus die die
ontologische situation jetzt genau die
die wir hinter platonischen sitzen der
platonischen tradition finden nämlich es
gibt gott es gibt es geistliche die
geistliche werde im allgemeinen aber
hier ist nur gott ich war nur von gott
und das problem ist dass wir als
körperliche dinge geschaffene dinge gott
nicht mit unseren eigenen macht
erreichen können
wir können sprach er einsetzen und die
beziehung zu gott beschreiben
aber die beziehung zu gott zu
beschreiben ist nicht gott zu erreichen
deswegen gab es immer in der in der
platonischen installation vor allem die
praxis muss gab es immer dann den
vorschlag dass man jenseits der sprache
kommen könnte und dann wieder runter und
dann versuchen das sprachlich zu äußern
wie das wie die erfahrung war was die
erfahrung bedeutet und was unser
jetziges zustand ist wenn wir diese
erfahrung nicht gerade genießen
diese frauen behaupten die mystische
erfahrungen gab zu haben aber das
behaupten zahlreiche philosophen platin
zum beispiel oder pseudo dns es gibt
etliche mystiker den angreifer
bonaventura usw
und da das diesem moment wo man mit gott
vereint wird das ist irgendwie jenseits
der philosophie aber was philosophisch
ist ist das problem zu beschreiben wo es
zu erklären wie man das über die diese
distanz überbrücken kann
und noch mehr sie haben eine theorie
warum das möglich ist nämlich das an
dass man durch also die durch
körperlichkeit körperlichkeit heißt so
was wie es eigentlich offenheit und
liebe es ist diese das ist der punkt
dieses themas dass man an dass man alle
andere sorgen und zwecke beseitigen soll
oder sie nur auf die geliebte oder in
diesem fall den geliebten konzentrieren
soll
und vielleicht wenn man das macht wird
man dann belohnt dadurch dass man ja nur
kurz vielleicht irgendwann darf man ihn
berühren oder in kontakt kommen
das und also natürlich sind die leute
ist die literarische quelle ist - aber
die der philosophische punkt ist
eigentlich der punkt den wir in der
platonischen tradition finden nämlich
alle sachen der sinnlichen welt
wegschaffen oder mindestens eine lust
und interesse an die körperliche welt
wechsel schaffen und sich nur auf das
geistige konzentrieren und das kann eine
platonische formans sein
das kann auch gott sein hier ist
natürlich gott aber der punkt ist dass
man für
diese so die die geistige welt offen
heißt die und die verdienen dann
irgendwie dieses übrigens ich würde fast
sagen was das merkt hält sagt ist
irgendwie ein bisschen tue es ist
natürlich schwer zu glauben dass sie
behauptet dass sie nie was sie hat nie
mühe gegeben oder sowas weil natürlich
betont sie immer wieder wie viel sie
leiden muss und wie viel sie nach ihnen
sehen muss das ist ihr das ist genau das
was sie leistet ist diese offenheit und
diese bereitschaft zu leiden werden sie
wartet bis gott kommt dass das ist das
gut doch sie diese diese sehen dann
verdient also erstens das dass sie eine
so genannte saison eine pakistanische
theorie haben die mit einer anthologie
verbunden ist und das drücken sie mit
den mitteln der des ministers aus aber
es passt eigentlich sehr gut so einer
gewissen art philosophie die im 13
jahrhundert natürlich sehr sehr wichtig
war und bei anderen autoren auch so
belegen ist das andere ist dass und das
werden wir auch wieder bei buy
marien ports sind es gibt auch eine idee
hier im hintergrund die vor allem bei hd
witz vorkommt nämlich dass wir wenn wir
näher zu gott kommen ein irgendwie eine
beziehung nichts neu schaffen sondern
wieder aufstellen die wir vorher hatten
nämlich weil die seele aus ewigkeit von
gott geschaffen würde
deswegen irgendwie ist eine fassung von
der seele oder eine fassung von jeder
person kann man noch mit gott wo sie
beschaffen würde
und wenn in diesen momenten wo er wird
dann zugang zu gott dann erwerben kann
wird sie sozusagen neu geschaffen wie
sie immer war
oder sie bekommt zurück das was sie
ursprünglich hatte haben natürlich ist
das wieder ein sehr nützliches thema das
die säle weg von gott gott feld und oder
dass die menschheit weg von gott fällt
durch uhr sonde nun zurück zu gott aber
es auch sehr platonisch also sehr ist
dass die zelle von einer geistlichen
verursache runter kommt und dann
zurückkommen muss das ist eigentlich ein
19 ist muss kurzum würde ich sagen nennt
wenn jemand nicht fragen würde
sind diese texte philosophisch ich würde
sagen erstens irgendwie nicht weil sie
behaupten nichts philosophie zu sein und
wenn man sagt philosophie ist das was
die auswahl so der autor muss behaupten
philosophie sein bevor ich bereit bin
was als bloße beschreiben dann ist das
natürlich keine philosophische texte die
sind nichts als philosophische texte
susan betitelt also das nicht aber es
gibt viele so fischer mindestens für das
typische annahmen und vielleicht sogar
eine ganze philosophische theorie hinter
der literarischen darstellung
und sogar eine eine bestimmte für das
häufige theorie nämlich die neue
platonische einstellung oder theorie von
der beziehung zwischen geschaffenen
mensch und gott wahrscheinlich heißt es
dass die also wenn sie überzeugt sind
dann sollen es wenn sie sich fragen ist
frauen mystik des 21 jahrhunderts ist
das viel los erzählt als philosophie die
richtige antwort ist fragen sie sich ob
neu platin ismus für das wärs manche
würden sagen nein
ich verbringe meine ganze zeit passt mit
neu platz muss und deswegen bin ich mehr
als überzeugt dass trittleitern israels
als bilder sowie zählt aber an dass
selbst wenn es diese sozusagen nicht
bereit sind zu hart das als das
natürlich nicht aristotelischen ist
klassische philosophie aber es ist passt
sehr gut in einem muster relation die
zurück zu platon geht und die wir auch
bei anderen zur weiblichen autoren der
antike gesehen haben zum beispiel nach
china
also ist eigentlich eine bestimmte art
philosophie die wir bei hdw und merkt
hilfen und das bestätigt eine behauptung
die ich immer wieder mache nämlich dass
man nicht pauschal sagen kann was es
bedeutet für diese teuren halt rennen
das sie dass sie frauen sind sie
tatsache dass diese zwei autoren und
frauen sind ermöglicht dass sie genau
diese strategie einsetzen um neutra
zionismus oder eine vielleicht etwas
übertrieben habe eine theorie zu äußern
die sehr ähnlich ist die neue platz muss
und das ist eigentlich sehr anders als
soldat als das was wir bei hildegard
gesehen haben also bei hildegard
doch eine gewisse gratis muss verhandeln
aber wirklich nur ethisch hier ist geht
nicht um ethik es geht um psychologie
und theologie
nächste woche werden wir besprechen und
wir werden sehen haben dass sie mit
ähnlichen themen arbeitet wie hatte
wechseln aber sie geht ein bisschen
weiter und wie gesagt vielleicht ein
bisschen zu weit
vielen dank
wenn jemand will ich habe noch kann das
hier vorne